der Name – die Namen
sein
aus (aus Italien)
seit
Mein Name ist Andrea Rossi.
Mein Vorname ist Andrea; Rossi ist der Familienname.
Ich bin dreiundzwanzig.
Ich komme aus Italien.
1 = eins
2 = zwei
3 = drei
4 = vier
5 = fünf
das Jahr – die Jahre
Ich wohne seit drei Jahren in Zürich.
ihr - euer
6 = sechs
7 = sieben
8 = acht
9 = neun
10 = zehn
die Gruppe – die Gruppen
Euer Kurs beginnt heute.
Es sind sieben Studenten in eurer Gruppe.
(sich) anmelden
die Anmeldung
möglich
der Prospekt – die Prospekte
Wo kann ich mich anmelden?
Eine Anmeldung für diesen Kurs ist nicht
mehr möglich.
Möchten Sie einen anderen Kurs wählen?
Geben Sie mir bitte einen Prospekt mit Ihrem
Angebot.
der Familienname
falsch
buchstabieren
Mein Familienname ist González.
Konzalez?
Das ist falsch.
Bitte buchstabieren Sie Ihren Namen.
G-O-N-Z-A-L-E-Z.
wir – unser
leicht
die Klasse
der Schüler – die Schüler
Wir lernen Deutsch.
Deutsch ist nicht leicht.
In unserer Klasse sind zwei Schülerinnen
und fünf Schüler.
der Kurs – die Kurse
der Unterricht
der Lehrer – die Lehrer
das Thema
Der Deutschkurs geht bis zum Sommer.
Wir haben Unterricht von 8 bis 12 Uhr.
Das ist unsere Deutschlehrerin.
Sie heißt Frau Müller.
Wir sprechen heute über das Thema „Essen
und Trinken“.
morgen
sehr
die Prüfung
einfach
Morgen habe ich die Prüfung "Start Deutsch
1".
Sie ist mir sehr wichtig.
Sie beginnt um 10 Uhr.
Man sagt zwar, sie ist ganz einfach.
Ich denke aber, sie ist sehr schwer.
müde
was
unter
Ich bin müde und gehe schlafen.
Oh!
Was ist das?
Ah!
Unter uns wohnt eine Familie mit drei Kindern.
erzählen
laut
anmachen
ihr – euch (Akkusativ)
sehen
leise
die Polizei
Mama!
Erzähl uns ein Märchen!
Nicht so laut, Oskar!
Das Baby schläft.
Mach das Licht an, Michaela!
Ich kann euch nicht sehen.
Seid leise.
Die Leute schlafen schon.
Genug, Kinder, oder ich hole die Polizei!
die Mutter – die Mütter
gleich
lachen
der Kopf
die Jacke – die Jacken
sich kümmern
Ich bin Erika.
Ich bin die Mutter von Michaela.
Und ich bin Begüm, die Mutter von Peter.
Mein Sohn und deine Tochter sind gleich alt.
Die Kinder lachen viel.
Nun tut mir der Kopf weh!
Peter!
Zieh dir eine Jacke an.
Es ist kalt.
Immer muss ich mich um dich kümmern!